what does it mean to be here tonight  really it's such an honor to be here  tonight it feels like  you know  i feel like i'm receiving five honorary  phds tonight like i'm a doctor now if  you know what i mean  it's just been a long and tough journey  and it's such a blessing for me to be  here i really can't believe it what  would it mean for this movie to win best  picture  i feel  of course honored to be recognized  because obviously  people are beginning to to remember a  message not to forget to love and  cherish your family no matter what  language you use  awesome  congratulations on everything thank you  so much thank you for having me  [Music]  you